all right so that weather is perfect for
summer barbecue kind of it would be a
little hot but it's okay so how about a
summer barbecue paired with your friends
your family and nevada craft brews wendy
forest is here to show us how to
properly pair a local brew with our
summer eats so what does the summer mean
to the nevada craft brewers association
like do you guys gear up for the summer
for sure okay um summer means backyard
barbecues
lots of food lots of cold drinks to help
with our hot temperatures right
so head to your local favorite brewery
we all have seasonal um beers which are
great for the summer i hear lighter
beers are more summery yeah okay
for sure
and we also make you can
just
in your own backyard you can make a
shandy you can make a birmosa have fun
with your beauty have you ever heard of
a beer mostly because i have not so i
cannot wait to talk about this so let's
talk about pairings because we're
pairing your beers with your
quintessential summer barbecue foods
whether it's you know sausage watermelon
right hot dogs right potato salad yes
all of it so if you have something spicy
maybe
carne asada okay you're going to do the
tacos ipas are definitely the way to go
with something spicy yeah these
peppercorns i love these little pigs who
doesn't love a little pickle um so
ipas they will intensify the spice
of anything that you're putting on the
grill
if you're going to do maybe some
sausages on the grill
the golden ale by astronomy ale works
works perfectly especially with like a
chicken sausage okay those two balance
each other out interesting what is the
balancing what's happening there there's
no science that goes into brewery so
flavors complement one another or they
damper one another so with the ipa and
the spiciness that's going to intensify
the flavors with the golden ale from
astronomy and a chicken sausage those
are just gonna kind of be even mellow
and be the best of friends wow okay and
all you do is you drink you you're
learning here okay so let's can we
please talk about these because i
couldn't believe these were beers yes so
summertime also means um shandies
rattlers beermosas um only you only need
two maybe three ingredients okay um so
you only need two or maybe three to feel
it too right
that's it
so this is a mango nada so we use zatron
that's a sour from craft house a little
bit of mango nectar chamoy and um you
have to have the tamarind chili straw
just for fun oh oh that's why see what i
did there okay oh this is cool
it's messy it's messy oh my god
but you have the spicy the tangy the
juicy
this is cool okay this is great what is
this one called again that's a mango
nada a mango okay and last last but not
least we've got one more show uh so um a
shandy is basically just lemonade with
your favorite um summer ale okay and
where can people get more information
about the nevada craft brewery
association yep if they go to
envybeer.com there's a list of all of
our brewery members throughout the
entire state i love it support local
drink local julia i'll send it to you